selling services of any kind try this  clothes when the person says i'm not  really sure i'm not sure if i want to  move forward today etc we say totally  understand what if this program were  perfect would you do it then they'll say  yes you say awesome well then what's the  difference between the perfect program  in this program tell me what's missing  and what happens is they'll have to  generate responses and usually people  are not very good at generating  responses when it comes to these types  of things especially on the spot and so  a lot of times people realize well i  guess there isn't anything missing and  you say totally understand then it might  just be afraid of making a mistake and i  totally understand too so why don't we  talk about what we have to make sure  that you don't feel that way and some of  the things that we do to ensure they get  what you want fair enough great you can  close the deal